the views and opinions expressed on this
program are those of the guests
appearing on the program
and do not necessarily reflect the views
and opinions of eight news now or next
our media group
we know that there are things that we
need to improve on and that's what we've
spent a lot of the interim doing
there's some things that need to be
thought through a little further
criminal justice reforms on the
forefront what's in store up in carson
city as we head toward the last month of
the legislative session
ripped the blinders off the whole world
to see
the systemic racism a renewed push for
police reform
after the guilty verdict for derrick
chauvin we look at the new push for a
billion congress
and the report is in we break down the
answers from nevada's secretary of state
to republican claims of voter fraud
[Music]
thank you for joining us here on
politics now i'm john langler at the
legislative session another key deadline
in carson city passed
this week bills that were not declared
exempt had to pass the house they
originated in some were exempt because
of funding
in all more than 130 bills sailed
through the senate and the assembly on
tuesday
so let's start in the assembly with a
bill that would seal some eviction
records during the pandemic
democrats passed assembly bill 141 it
would seal eviction for
non-payment and extend how long those
evictions would take to be processed
democrats say the measure will help
people who lose their homes be able to
rent again
several landlords though testify this
simply creates more demand and higher
rents
a bill to allow the attorney general's
office to do pattern and practice
investigations of police departments
passed the assembly unanimously ab58
lets the ag
decide if something is the action of a
rogue cop or a wider
systemic issue within the department a
bill that would allow
college athletes to make money off of
their image pass the assembly
they could use their likeness name or
image and sponsorships with
a few limits similar bills have been
passed in other states as well
a bill to rework nevada's unemployment
system past the state
senate sb 75 gives people more
flexibility on benefit eligibility
it also provides some relief on their
unemployment tax rate
but it does not address a major overhaul
of deters software
or other technological issues which have
come to the forefront during the
pandemic
a bill that tackles hair style
discrimination
also moved forward senate bill 327
allows people to have
knots locks or braids at work or public
schools
republican senator ira hansen was the
only no vote
a bail reform bill made it through the
senate sb 369 requires a court to only
impose bail or conditions of release
if they are quote the least restrictive
means necessary
right now the standard is for a court
for the court rather is to show good
cause
all right so with the session a little
more than halfway complete
what is next in carson city well we
wanted to speak with leadership from
both sides
democrat senate majority leader nicole
cannazzaro works in the clark county
da's office in her day job
i spoke with her about criminal justice
reforms and whether the session may go
into overtime
whether it's police reform or bail
reform a lot of
talk of reform in in carson city right
now specifically
senate bill 369 made it through the
senate
what is your expectation of it actually
getting to the governor's desk
you know we've been working throughout
the interim on
issues related to police reform and to
bail reform last session we put together
an
interim study that was chaired by
senator dallas harris
to address and look at the issues around
bail reform and the cash bail system
to ensure that when people are you know
arrested for an offense
that they're treated fairly we know that
there are things that we need to improve
on and that's what we've spent a lot of
the interim doing and i think you're
seeing
the fruits of that labor come forward in
the form of senate bill 369 as you
mentioned
and a few others that we've been working
on senate bill 369 is of course still
going to give
courts the latitude to impose bail or to
impose restrictions
like house arrest or stay away orders
to ensure that the safety of victims can
be at the forefront for
individuals who are maybe in
involved in a dangerous and violent
crime and i think that this is not only
aligning
with reforming that system of cash fail
so that it is a fair system
but also ensuring that we can keep the
community safe
you know in my day job i've been a
prosecutor for close to 10 years now
and so this is something that i have
some familiarity with
but definitely know how important it is
that we assure the safety of the
community
while at the same time making sure that
the system that we
that we come into contact with that we
rely on um
is is fair and is just when it comes to
police reform um
there have been some measures that you
know the sheriff sheriff lombardo here
uh
seems willing willing to uh see some of
the reforms that have been put in place
uh he would suggest with clark county
elsewhere across nevada
in your experience up in carson city now
is there a willingness
by other lawmakers to have the same kind
of reform put in place
i think so we're seeing that in a number
of senate bills
i mentioned senator dallas harris has
been working on a number of those issues
we've passed a couple of those that
require for police
for police units and law enforcement
agencies
to have in their policies and procedures
de-escalation techniques
that those are things that have to be
taken into consideration when we're
looking at use of force policies
we also have seen some legislation come
over that is bipartisan in nature from
the assembly that deals
with the use of force by police officers
speaker fryerson has a bill that deals
with post training
what is left to do what are some big
things that are still on the horizon
there was discussion in the beginning
about trying to
bring more revenue into nevada issues
with regards to
mining taxes uh internet sales etc
um are those still potentially on the
table here there's there's obviously
deadlines on
that were coming pretty quick yeah i
mean we still do have quite a bit of
work to do in the legislature
we've just had a deadline where the
bills sort of switch houses so in order
to get any of these policy proposals
over the final finish line
um we still have to go through either
the assembly or the senate depending on
on which house the bill is in
at this point so we still have quite a
bit of work to do to accomplish
our policy objectives um and with
respect to some of the revenue
conversations
we know that the state of nevada is
still in need of revenue for things like
education
those are important things that every i
think parent recognizes teacher
recognizes child recognizes
every legislator recognizes we've got to
do more
to ensure that our students are getting
a quality education
potential for a special session if
things don't get done on time and if
that does happen
is that us should that should we be
disappointed in that as
observers of the legislative session or
was that expected to begin with
you know i always say and that 120 days
flies by faster than you think it will
uh and so for 120 days you know we are
committed to the business of the state
of nevada
i have every anticipation that we are
going to end that business on time in
120 days
but we do have some outstanding issues
with respect to federal funds
um that we're still awaiting guidance on
and so there may come a time where
we have to continue that conversation
so ms canizaro as she mentioned is a
clark county prosecutor
republican co-deputy minority floor
leader tom roberts is a former metro
police assistant chief
he opposed abolishing the death penalty
but has signed on to
some of the criminal justice reforms
discussed in carson city
he spoke with our david charns and they
started discussing bail reform
i think we got to be careful that like
right now we're experiencing in las
vegas
is you have visitors from california
that are coming here
they're being caught with guns and
things on the strip
and they're being let out immediately
uh you know based on a a relaxation of
of bail and or you know releasing people
with no bail
and they're not showing up for court and
so that gets word out
to folks that are traveling here that do
those kind of things that
you know you're not you're gonna get
trouble you're not gonna face any
consequences and so
i think that could be a byproduct of of
too much
relaxation of of bail uh
you know there needs to be some kind of
risk assessment to people
we need to follow that don't need to be
too lenient we need to keep the public
safe
but same time respect people's rights i
don't know where the governor sits on
the assisted suicide but he was pretty
quick to say that he didn't support
getting rid of the death penalty
um so both of these issues like i
mentioned have been brought up
before uh i i
i assume you don't support either of
them but do they
have a chance of actually becoming law
for that the death penalty cases
i mean there's certainly a good argument
for the cost
and the fact that uh you know nobody has
been executed in this state
um but however i think the da's the
district attorneys in the state
brought up some good ballot arguments
that it you know
you you start with death penalty cases
quite often and then you
you you get down to a lower uh you know
through a plea agreement to you know a
life without
and so they're they're really taking any
death penalty cases forward
if you lower it to the to where
you're starting at a life without then
and quite often you're you're going
below that a knee plea deal and so
they felt detec it took away some
leverage uh
in plea deals uh you know or you know
dealing some of these cases out
and i i felt i needed to support him in
that effort assisted suicide or the
death with dignity bill
i have not heard that bill yet but you
know
i i need to hear both sides the big
things that
police groups don't want to see is this
ban on no knock warrants
and and that kind of stuff so what do
you think
should be implemented and and what do
you think shouldn't
so you know i believe in uh
involving community members in the
decision decision-making process
and i've said this before it's like like
at metro you have the
multicultural advisory council right and
so you have citizens
that are involved in policy making uh
for the department
and your crime fighting you know they
their community members they
they participate in the process and the
outcomes that you get from that are
great
which is why i had a bill to add one
person to the post commission which is
police officers standards and training
commission
that establishes all the training for
police officers from the state
i wanted to add one civilian actually
the speaker had a bill to add two
i killed my bill i signed on to him i
think
some of the use of force and you know
there's bills out
there that uh that wouldn't allow police
officers to rest on misdemeanors
you know you could only issue citations
you know there's
there are challenges with that there's
some stat there's some things in statute
that require you to make arrests like
domestic violence or dui
or you have a trespass for instance if i
go
somebody's trespassing on your property
and you call me as a police officer and
i show up i write them a ticket and they
still refuse to leave
what am i supposed to do right you know
all right write them another ticket
you know so there's some things that
need to be thought
through a little further
both of those interviews are available
now on eight news now dot com
so there are two big dates on the
horizon at the legislative session
may 4th the next economic forum tells
the state how much money
they have to work with may 14th is the
committee passage deadline in the second
house
the last day of the legislative session
is may 31st
shooting down election fraud claims next
on politics now
republicans made thousands of complaints
about the last election
nevada's secretary of state issues its
report on what really happened
you're watching politics now
this week former minneapolis police
officer derek shovin was found guilty in
the death of george floyd
soon afterwards the department of
justice announced an investigation into
minneapolis police
attorney general merrick garland says
it'll look into whether the department
engages in
unlawful policing and discrimination the
investigation by the feds is expected to
take at least a year
the case is historic the derrick chauvin
case police officers are rarely
charged fewer even convicted for killing
someone while on duty
in congress that led to renewed talk
about a potential police reform bill
vice president kamala harris says police
reforms still need to happen
she urged the senate to pass the police
reform measure named after george floyd
republicans are against it alabama
senator tommy tuberville said this about
what comes next
i want to make sure that we back our
police you know because there's a lot of
good ones a lot of good ones
a measure of justice isn't the same
as equal justice this verdict
brings us a step closer and
the fact is we still have work to do
from washington to discuss the latest
conversations in washington
alex where do things stand right now
hey there well democrats are really
pushing for passage of their package the
george floyd justice and policing act
and it is really
a sweeping bill that makes quite a few
changes including
you know on a national level banning
police choke holds for example and no
knock warrants
but it also would end qualified immunity
for police officers so it would make it
easier to sue
police officers for wrongdoing or
abusive power
and that issue right there is perhaps
the biggest sticking point and the
biggest
issue that republican lawmakers have
with the police reform bill that
democrats are proposing
they say they are completely republicans
say they are completely against
ending qualified immunity for police
officers some of them told us that you
know police officers jobs are already
hard enough already
as it is and that they see this as
essentially taking away
any support for those officers
is there an ability to find compromise
on capitol hill despite the fact there's
this difference of how
police reform should look can
republicans and democrats come to some
sort of a middle ground
well it definitely seems like they're
trying but i will say we saw this play
out last year after george floyd
was killed you know democrats were again
pushing for this same police reform bill
they again did pass it in the u.s house
last year as well
but republicans you know had their own
version of a police reform package
that was completely different and both
sides you know didn't really budge
even though the george floyd police
justice and policing act passed in the
u.s house
the senate never took it up in a
committee never tried to amend it didn't
debate it it didn't go anywhere
and so this time around democratic
congresswoman karen bass is taking the
lead and she says
she is in conversations with republican
senator
tim scott to try to forge some
compromise and she says these
negotiations are happening in good faith
but whether that's going to result in
some kind of compromise that
gets 60 votes in the u.s senate and then
also gets enough support
from you know the more progressive
members of the u.s house and gets enough
support to pass in the house as well
well that still remains to be seen
certainly a major issue in washington
minnesota and here in las vegas as well
alex limon thank you for joining us
nevada's secretary of state says there
was no proof of widespread election
fraud from november of 2020 however
the office is investigating nearly two
dozen cases stemming from last year's
election
the office put out a report last week on
the complaints
that the nevada republican party
delivered last month claiming
it had more than a hundred thousand
examples of fraud well out of nearly
four thousand
dead people they claim actually voted a
review from the office of vital
statistics found only
10 deceased voters in nevada had ballots
cast in their names
the review also found 10 other people
may have voted twice
the secretary of state's office says
none of the gop's other accusations were
valid
several judges including the state
supreme court threw out lawsuits to try
and overturn the election results
next on politics now getting in the race
i just think we can do it better up next
i ask sheriff joe lombardo about why he
may
run for governor you're watching
politics now
there's also a topic in carson city as
we discussed earlier in the program
this week on good day las vegas i
interviewed sheriff joe lombardo about
those bills and also
his potential run for governor
there are bills being considered
measures to
increase accountability increase
oversight on
on police departments nationwide
do you support some of the measures
being considered for example up in
carson city at the legislative session
to to add more uh guidelines and to add
more restrictions i shouldn't say
restrictions but more
rules essentially for engagement in the
field
yes absolutely support them and and
fortunately a lot of what they're
talking about
excuse me are already in place here at
metro um
they're uh ponyian or they're copying
off our policies that we have in place
to make it uh standard practice across
the entire state
so you know unfortunately the smaller
police department sometimes are slow to
move or they need help from a larger
police department because of resources
availability
and they use the the policies and
procedures and the language
associated with how we conduct business
from a big department onto their
department and
it's it's i'm actually pretty proud of
what i'm seeing up there
because they're taking what we've
seen and what we've adjusted for and
what we're putting into place
into place across the state and then in
turn you're seeing similar actions
across the united states with all police
departments let's switch gears a little
bit
sheriff you recently went public with
the las vegas review journal about your
potential plans to change jobs and
potentially run for governor
where do things stand right now for the
possible run for another office in 2022
well i appreciate the question but i'm
still in the same situation as i
described to the review journal
you know my primary focus right now is
being your clark county sheriff
that's what i was voted in for
to do but yeah but you know you look at
new challenges in life and you
and you figure out what you're going to
do into the future
and maybe you can affect some larger
changes in another
position and i will make a decision on
that here in
in the very short future more than
likely in the next few weeks on what i'm
planning on doing for the state of
nevada
what is it about the current
administration that maybe would motivate
you to consider running for governor
i just think we can do it better and
that would be
the line i would use can you be more
specific about doing it better
no i'm worried about my job as a sheriff
right now
all right just a brief response there
from sheriff lombardo meanwhile a
potential republican field for governor
slowly taking shape north las vegas
mayor john lee recently switched to the
republican party
and this week he announced a 17 county
all the counties
nevada campaign swing starting in
esmeralda county now
lee has not officially announced he's
running for governor yet but this might
be
first salvo well this week we're
bringing back our
following the money segment and first
quarter fundraising totals are in we're
focusing on a couple of nevada's key
races for 2022.
as you see behind me there democratic
senator catherine cortez masto raised
2.3
million dollars in the first quarter she
has about 4.7 million dollars
in cash on hand as for democratic
congresswoman suzy lee she raised about
607
thousand dollars for her district 3 race
as you can see
she has 484 thousand dollars of cash
on hand and congressman stephen horsford
raised 363 000
he is in of course congressional
district four and he has seven hundred
fifty seven thousand dollars in cash on
hand
no major republican challengers have
taken shape yet
you're watching politics now
finally here on politics now florida
governor ron desantis is going to be at
the basque fry fundraiser held by adam
laxalt every year here in nevada
the republican event is going to be
august 14th in gardnerville
no other speakers have been announced
yet but in the past it's been aligned
with cpac
former vice president mike pence among
others have spoken there before
we'll see you next week here on politics
now thanks for watching